if the literature being read to the
child isn't entertaining to the parent
throw it away
[Music]
children's literature can be meaningful
and compelling to us one of the reasons
why we read these great stories to
children is to prepare their minds to
receive truth it is important that these
stories have is moral truths about
goodness
and the moral imagination is not just
being formed and children it's being
formed in all of us the good children's
literature the great ceaseless argues
and others argue is also really good for
adults adults should not only remember
their childhood they should keep it
children are naturally wondrous things
they see are new things we see are new
too you just don't see them as well
children's literature can help you
recover your childhood children's
literature is part of our tradition it's
part of our heritage if you hear a
particular title so for example Alice's
Adventures in Wonderland please don't
judge the story solely based on the
movie read the story itself get into the
story when you read Treasure Island try
to smell the salt air try to get in the
company of these pirates feel the boards
on the deck of the Espanyol
enter that world I'd like to invite you
to enter into the world of children's
literature because it's the real world
but conditioned by delight we live in a
wonderful world and I think that there
is beauty around us and one of the real
virtues of reading these stories is to
get us to see these things again
Christie I'm Dan Copeland
professor of education at Hillsdale
College I'm David Whalen professor of
English Literature at Hillsdale College
let's begin
you